[Music]
Thanksgiving my family's gonna be there
who does what in the kitchen like what's
your role game if if somebody if my
fence mom Chris will be in town okay
and if she and Ben will take the kids
and I all have crap set up I'll have
t-ball of soccer I'll let anything bring
it up if they will play with the kids
and just let me cook it is heaven for me
I will make homemade bread
I'll make steppin I'll make a turkey
I'll make gravy
I'll make sweet potato pudding on the
pies just let me have that day in the
kitchen we are going to be surrounded by
beauty we talked a little bit about the
part of what made you so interested in
this but I was wondering like with all
you've done in your career at this point
why was now the right time to try to
tackle such a powerful emotional role
like it felt like it was or now or two
years ago in a sense I don't know in a
way it's just you just kind of grow into
a space where you feel like why not you
know what do I have to what do I have to
lose I'm a grown up I've been doing this
a long time it's the same skills no
matter what role you're you're doing you
might as well when someone offers you
something like this you might as well
just grab after it you did a beautiful
job I might add as well now again ready
for the premiere you're coming out
you're getting all dolled up you look
fantastic you make sure the kids are
okay and does that include like taking
Regina George for a walk like you check
what was that what we have chickens
we've chickens they want each of them
are villains and Regina George is one of
them you know she was a very mean girl
and she happens to be our favorite but
her name is Regina George and we're
we're waiting for her to lay soon maybe
maybe we'll have X this we
maybe nests it's like Instagram gold I'm
just gonna say you know what I mean I
don't know I'm surprised I'm surprised
that people were into the chicken
walking but I'm happy
you